I'm not saying he's going to beat Canelo
I'm not saying he's even go that
direction nor should he all I'm saying
is where he's at look what he's doing
despite how you feel about him look what
these brothers pulled off sold out arena
in Dallas one of the biggest papers of
the Year got the likes of a Nate Diaz
who hated on this type of fighting for
years got him to a main event
comes into the arena in a tank oh and
his brother competed in WWE was a
massive event got a private plane and
made the fight these are two kids who
started Ohio with a cell phone and
they're the biggest names in
entertainment all I'm saying is look
what two kids from Ohio did with a cell
phone on YouTube he's the main event in
a sold out Dallas Arena it was the Talk
of the Town dude and his brother is
competing in the WWE at the highest
level this is insane